you know he's one of those jobs where
you kind of think oh how hard can that
be but they really do put you through it
I have never begun a recording session
without wishing it was already over
because I understand woody is clenched
all the time he's clenched they were
sorry there is something he's got I've
explained or come on guys it's all back
and you can't move the microphone is
right there and you can't move and you
have to be like this it's like and then
they saved the last thing for you
usually at the end of a very long
workday is the grunts woody climbing up
a bunch of books onto a thing it's okay
could you do grunts of climbing up okay
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
they are gleeful at making you ring
every possible meaning from a line they
eat when you're in like the young acting
repetitions the exercise repetitions
where you have a very simple cue and a
very simple line and the cue might be
would you like some more coffee and the
line you have to say is coffee you think
I want more coffee boy do I need more
coffee so if you would say coffee do I
want coffee boy do I need more coffee
okay and you're gonna say it every
conceivable way you kill and all I'm
gonna say is do this would you like more
coffee coffee coffee boy do I need more
coffee
good thank you would you like some more
coffee coffee coffee boy do I need some
more I'll try it with a little more
something to it because we do this is
this is a bit important see cuz King
Kong is out from these events mash the
coffee coffee please sir I need some
more coffee that's ready more coffee
coffee coffee please sir I need some
work off with the lights more coffee
coffee coffee please circle on I need
some more coffee what do you like some
more coffee coffee please
what it is like
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know American accent anymore
yeah I did the commercial the other day
as Tom Holland and I was like hey guys
how you doing like you're from Kingston
[Music]
you